Secretary of State Rex Tillerson and
Russian Foreign Minister Sergei Lavrov
will also attend the meeting with
President Trump and President Putin
Tillerson the retired ExxonMobil CEO has
more experience dealing with Putin than
anyone in the Trump administration and
that could help the president navigate
this morning's meeting major Garrett is
in Hamburg Germany with Putin's
relationship with US leaders major good
morning good morning president Trump has
allotted only 30 minutes for his meeting
with Vladimir Putin with translation
that doesn't leave much time beyond
pleasantries but for these world leaders
even those could be by turns interesting
and awkward I have no relationship with
a mother then he called me a genius the
other day Putin he said Donald Trump is
brilliant at times candidate Donald
Trump appeared taken by Vladimir Putin's
flatter maybe we'll have a good
relationship maybe we'll have a horrible
relationship as president he must now
keep his guard up Putin as a trained KGB
officer he has never caught off guard
and he he's never short of words Angela
stent has written extensively on Putin's
relationship with American presidents
and has met with him a dozen time he has
spent most of his adult life
understanding the strengths and
weaknesses of his partners and opponents
and how to maximize those for his own
benefit Putin has charmed other American
presidents most memorably George W Bush
I finally to be very straightforward and
trustworthy I was able to get a sense of
his soul mr. Bush thought Putin was a
true ally especially after 9/11 he
hosted Putin on his Texas ranch and on a
fishing trip in Maine Putin shattered
that optimism with his 2008 invasion of
neighboring Georgia the first sign of
Putin's nationalist and expansionist
foreign policy relations with former
President Obama further soured when
Putin seized Crimea housed renegade
national security leaker Edward Snowden
and backed Syrian dictator Bashar
al-assad to increase their body language
at the 2013 g8 summit in Ireland
illustrating the
something mr. Obama later described he's
got that kind of slouched looking like
the board kid in the back of the
classroom stem says Putin was insulted
and wants to regain prestige with mr.
Trump he needs to come out of this
looking stronger and looking as if the
relationship he had with President Obama
but that's over and that President Trump
is gonna respect him Putin and his team
always look for the advantage that means
there are risks for the new American
president one of the dangers is that you
could get President Trump to agree to
something which he might then have to
rollback we're not getting along with
Russia at all mr. Trump has maintained
all Obama era sanctions imposed for
election meddling in February the
president said relations with Russia
were too toxic for progress Putin
probably assumes that he can't make a
deal with me anymore because politically
it would be unpopular for a politician
to make a dip in diplomatic circles
there is a legendary story about Putin's
research and attempts to intimidate he
brought a large black Labrador to his
very first meeting with German
Chancellor Angela Merkel after learning
that Merkel was afraid of dogs the
meeting continued but Merkel got a very
real sense of Putin's methods White
House aides have kept mr. Trump's
reparations for this meeting simple and
straightforward reminding him to seek
short-term US objectives without seeking
any big breakthroughs Gayle's that dog
story very telling thank you very much
major Garrett in Hamburg